.
IT IS STEADILY WEARING DOWN
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS AND
CIVILIANS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THESE UKRAINIAN FIGHTERS
KNOW IT WON'T BE LONG NOW THE
RUSSIANS ARE GETTING CLOSER
FIRING HEAVY EMISSION INTO THIS
DENSE FOREST EVERY DAY.
>> LEATHER MAYOR SHOWS US WHERE
--
AND MUCH BIGGER ROUNDS HAVE
FALLEN CLOSER TO THE CAMP.
INCOMING FIRE LOOMS STEADILY
NEARBY.
AS WE HAIL --
THE THAT'S ANTI-TANK WEAPONS
SUPPLIED BY WESTERN ALLIES WERE
HUGELY AFFECTED EARLIER IN THE
WAR, BUT THEY'RE NOT THE WEAPON
UKRAINE NEEDS MORE'S FOR THIS
FIGHT IN THE EAST.
>> YOU CAN HEAR.
IT EVERY ONE OF OUR HEAVY SHOTS,
THEY MAKE TEN OR 20.
IT'S BECAUSE WE LACK ARTILLERY.
OUTGUNNED BY THE RUSSIANS,
OUTNUMBERED ALSO.
>> OF COURSE THEY'RE COMING,
MAXIME SAYS.
AND THERE ARE MANY MORE OF
THEM.
THEN US.
>> THE POSITION IN THIS FOREST,
A SHORT DECISION FROM RUSSIAN
LINES, ARE ALL VOLUNTEERS WHO
SIGNED UP.
FOUR WEEKS THEY WERE WAITING,
READY TO CARRY OUT --
TO ATTACK ANY RUSSIAN CONVOYS
TRYING THEIR LUCK ON THE NEARBY
ROAD.
>> IF, WHEN, RUSSIANS DECIDE TO
MOVE THROUGH AND TAKE THIS
TERRITORY, IT IS UNLIKELY THE
SOLDIERS --
THEY WILL JUST FEEL MORE OF THE
SAME.
HEAVY WEAPONS, ARTILLERY,
ROCKET FIRE, THE BIG HEAVY
WEAPONS THAT RUSSIA IS USING TO
DRIVE UKRAINIAN FORCES BACK
STEADILY, SLOWLY ACROSS THIS
REGION.
RUSSIA'S BIG WEAPONS DON'T JUST
FALL IN THE FOREST.
--
HERE, RUSSIA'S ARTILLERY
DESTROYED --
SIX PEOPLE OUTSIDE HIS
SUPERMARKET WERE INJURED WHERE
CLUSTER BRONZE DROPPED AROUND
THEM.
VON LET'S ALSO SCATTERED OVER
THIS APARTMENT COMPLEX, KILLING
A MAN.
TERRIFYING MANY MORE PEOPLE.
>> VALENTIN'S SAYS THE
EXPLOSIONS BLEW DEBRIS OVER HER
BED.
EVERY NIGHT SHE TRIES TO BLOCK
OUT THE NOISE OF WAR WITH THE
PILLAR.
>> IN BAKHMUT, SOUTHEAST OF --
THE EXPLOSIONS ARE EVEN GREATER
IN NUMBER IN POWER, TEARING
APART PEOPLES HOMES AS THEY
HUGS HUDDLED BENEATH BASEMENTS.
--
ALMOST EVERY HOME, HAS SOMEONE
LIVING IN IT.
ALMOST EVERY HOMERS FELT
RUSSIAN FIREPOWER.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
RELUCTANT TO LEAVE.
>> MARINA FEEL SHE HAS NOWHERE
TO GO.
THE STRAIN OF STAYING IS
UNBEARABLE.
>> SHE SAYS WE DON'T HAVE GAS,
WE DON'T HAVE POWER, WE DON'T
HAVE WATER, BUT WE ONLY WANT
THE SHOOTING TO STOP.
IN THE DONBAS, RUSSIA'S
UNMATCHED ARTILLERY IS
UNSTOPPABLE FORCE, WITH NO
CONCERN FOR CIVILIAN SUFFERING.
IT IS STEADILY OVERPOWERING
UKRAINE DEFENSES.
>> ROCKETS FALLING OVER --
JUST A SHORT DISTANCE WE'RE
FROM WHERE WE ARE, WITH SUCH
REGULARITY, OFFICIALS ARE
SAYING EVERY DAY PEOPLE SHOULD
GET OUT WHILE THEY STILL CAN.
THEY WANT TO AVOID A REPEAT OF
WHAT IS CURRENTLY HAPPENING FOR
THE EAST, IN LUHANSK, THE CITY
THAT IS ALMOST COMPLETELY
ENCIRCLED, UNDER CONSTANT
BOMBARDMENT DAY AND NIGHT, AND
THERE STILL SEEMS TO BE ABOUT
15,000 PEOPLE THERE.
THIS ALL ADDS UP TO A GRINDING
SENSE OF INEVITABILITY IN THIS
WAR FOR THE DONBAS.